في تونس انطلقت الحمله الانتخابيه
للانتخابات التشريعيه المزبعه تنظيمها يوم
السابع عشر من ديسمبر المقبل والتي يشارك
فيها 1055 مرشحا من المستقلين ومن
المتهمين لاحزاب واطراف سياسيه دائما
لمسار الخامس والعشرين من جوبيه 2021 اما
الاحزاب السياسيه المعارضه فقد اعلنت
النقطاتها لهذه الانتخابات على خلفيات ما
تعتبرهم الرئيس قصص سعيد ورفضا للقانون
الانتخابي الجديد
وحول هذه الانتخابات والحمله الانتخابيه
الخاصه بها ينضم الينا من تونس العاصمه
مراسل الفرنسي نور الدين نور الدين صباح
الخير واهلا بك نور الدين هل تبتسم هذه
الحمله الانتخابيه اليوم بالحماس
بالمشاركه الكثيفه يعني كيف هو طبيعها مع
بدايه انطلاقها
نعم هذه هو قانون الحمله الانتخابيه
انطلقت منذ ساعات لكن على الارض الى حدود
هذه اللحظه على الاقل هناك في مدينه
اريانه حيث اتواجد لا توجد اي او لا يوجد
اي مظهر من مظاهر هذه الحمله الانتخابيه
الحياه عاديه ايضا حتى بالنسبه للمترشحين
وهنا في هذه الدايره هناك مترشحين اثنين
لا يوجد اي نشاط باستثناء هذه المعلقه
التي ترينها ورائي والتي تتضمنوا البيان
الانتخابي لاحد المترشحين الحمله خلال
ساعات الاولى يمكن القول انها غائبه تماما
وربما تتواصلوا هناك ان يتواصل هذا الفطور
وايضا يتواصل غياب الحملات الدعائيه
التي تواصلوا الى يوم الخامس عشر ديسمبر
وهناك العديد من الاسباب بحسب المراقبين
وايضا بيحاسب الخبراء في المجال الانتخابي
ان هذه الانتخابات تاتي في سياق مختلف
اولا هذا السياق هو اعلان اغلب الاحزاب
سياسيه وخاصه الاحزاب المعارضه مقاطعها
لهذه الانتخابات ثانيا ان هذه الانتخابات
تجري اليوم على قاعده اقتراع جديده وهي
قاعده الاقتراع على الافراد وربما هذا
يجعل المترشحين ليس لهم درايه او ليس لهم
خبره في العمل الدعائي هذا الى جانب الوضع
الاجتماعي الاقتصادي الذي يقول مراقبون
انه يؤثر على التونسيون وخاصه في هذه
الحمله الانتخابيه الى حدود هذه اللحظه
كما قلت الوضع عادي لا توجد لا يوجد اي
مظهر من مظاهر هذه الحمله الانتخابيه
ننتظر خلال الساعات القادمه ربما ايضا حتى
الايام القادمه ربما يتطوروا هذا المشهد
رغم كما قلت انه هناك مخاوف حقيقيه اولا
من فطور هذه الحمله الانتخابيه وثانيا من
عزوه على هذه الانتخابات تماما في خلال
يوم الاقتراع هذا ما اكدته العديد من
الجمعيات والمنظمات المهتمه باشياء
الانتخابي في البلاد نعم
شكرا جزيلا لك مراسلنا من تونس العاصمه
نوردين المباركيه على هذه التفاصيل